après deux semaines d'audience et à
quelques jours du verdict du troisième
procès de patrick dils
les jurés de la cour d'assises du rhône
ont entendu aujourd'hui la détresse des
familles des deux petites victimes mais
aussi celle des parents de l'accusé
culpabilité contre innocence chacun est
resté sur ses positions dans une
ambiance particulièrement lourde
a lyon le reportage de stéphanie perez
et salah a gravi le père de patrick dils
réconforté par son avocat il n'a pas pu
assister à la fin de l'audience
épuisée nerveusement épuisé d'avoir à
reparler de ce fameux dimanche où sa vie
a basculé
épuisée avec sa femme de rechercher dans
sa mémoire les détails qui pourraient
prouver l'innocence de leur fils seize
ans après les faits à la barre
jacqueline deal avec des mots simples
répète inlassablement que son fils n'est
pas coupable
et comme je l'aï dit à la cour si
vraiment j'avais eu le moindre petit
doute
et puis que j'avais eu des preuves je
serai pas là en face de vous je me
serais suicidé parce que j'aurais pas
supporté d'avoir engendré à monstres
pour les familles des deux petites
victimes
la journée est également très
douloureuse une psychologue soutient la
maman de cyril lorsque celle ci évoque
son petit garçon le visages rougis de
larmes
il aurait eu 23 ans cette année de lui
il ne me reste plus qu'une tombe une
pierre froide les parents à bout qui
reste convaincu de la culpabilité de
deal
qu'on nous amène la preuve qu'il n'est
pas coupable quand nous la même approche
jusqu'à présent il est coupable
on a un dossier il a raconté je voulais
dire combien de fois où j'en ai mis tout
ce qu'il a fait pour tuer nos enfants
c'est quelque chose épouvantable de
repasser co2 bien avoir la tête libre
ça pique ça fait 16 ans que ça dure on
ne m'écoute et c'est à 4 verres qui nous
font qu'ils nous pourrons faire
innocents pour les siens coupable pour
les familles des victimes chaque jour la
balance à peser d'un côté puis de
l'autre
l'émotion parce que toujours aussi vive
mais après deux semaines de procès le
mystère de montigny-lès-metz n'est
toujours pas éclaircies